[Musique]
et on passe en live normalement
hello tout le monde est-ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer que vous
m'entendez et est-ce que Maxime tu peux
dire quelques mots pour voir vérifier
que le son fonctionne chez
Maxime
moi je t'entends ok ok je veux juste que
tu parles pour vérifier que
les gens du public nous disent qu'ils
nous entendent
bonjour tout le monde
moi je peux voir les commentaires
quelque part
tu peux aller sur
sur Sainte-Foy
qui a l'air déjà tellement mieux préparé
que le premier c'est fou comme on
progresse vite donc aujourd'hui j'ai le
grand plaisir d'accueillir
Maxime l'embrège donc alias filoxime
de confort Maxime est-ce que tu peux
tenter aussi rapidement
et la connexion est assez pourrie donc
voilà j'espère que tout tiendra bien
je veux dire qu'a priori la connexion
est pas très lié à la qualité de la
maison que
ben oui non non oui c'est des vieilles
c'est plus la qualité de
l'infrastructure en général
une vieille baraque tous les murs sont
tordus pour faire tenir l'armoire c'est
complètement galère donc voilà mais a
priori la connexion là ça va
il y en a qui se plaignent des
connexions belges est-ce que tu peux
commencer par te présenter rapidement
alors oui
je m'appelle Maxime Lambrecq donc je
suis de formation juriste et philosophe
et j'ai donc
je te fais un peu la bio où je te fais
la version courte
on prend le temps un petit peu
donc la bio né en 1985 donc en gros j'ai
fait mes tests doctorat sur la
philosophie de propriété intellectuel
d'environnement numérique
à l'Université de Louvain ou du coup je
parlais pas mal de des justifications du
droit d'auteur et la propriété
intellectuelle et ses mutations
aujourd'hui etc et puis j'ai travaillé
pas mal d'années comme chercheurs
endroits Internet et comment soignant et
alors c'est à l'occasion je devais pas
mal de cours d'éthique un peu partout à
Bruxelles à Mons à Lille à
Louvain-la-Neuve et
représente ses cours que je commençais à
avoir plein d'illustrations plein
d'extrait vidéo que je m'amusais à
passer à mes étudiants que je me suis
dit tiens serait cool si je faisais
comme les comme les youtubeurs à la mode
n'est-ce pas si je me lançais aussi en
tout cas dans des vidéos un peu à la
mode jump cut c'est nerveux et tout ça
avec voilà des blagues
alors les premières vidéos étaient un
petit peu trop nerveuse un peu trop de
blagues un petit peu trop dense un petit
peu trop ne zappez pas maintenant ça
c'est un petit peu calmé mais donc du
coup j'ai lancé cette chaîne phyloxime
où on parle d'éthique qui est une
politique avec des images d'animaux
rigolos et des gifs je crois que c'est
toujours la description sur Youtube et
pas mal d'éthique du climat aussi depuis
ces dernières ces derniers mois ces
dernières années
et du coup il y a un moment où tu t'es
dit je vais me lancer sur Youtube
comment ça s'est fait
à la base c'était vraiment
[Musique]
tu m'entends toujours ouais YouTube
c'était vraiment juste un médium pour
est-ce que c'est moi qui frise ce que
c'est les je ne sais pas
donc Youtube c'est vraiment juste un
médium pour pour mettre les vidéos
quelque part et pour l'envoyer à mes
étudiants quoi c'est encore de vidéos
que je donnais cours à Mons et alors
j'avais terminé la vidéo encore le matin
avant mon cours en pyjama puis je
lançais le plaude avant de partir pour
mon train une heure et demie du coup
transport en commun et puis la vidéo
était arrivée pour le coup mais donc
c'était vraiment ça et puis je me suis
dit bon ben voilà si on peut le mettre
en public du coup j'ai refait une
version de la vidéo et pour des
collègues pour d'autres cours et tout ça
pour voir voilà voir si ça mord mais
j'ai pas forcément une ambition qui est
d'enquérir le parquet mais bon
apparemment ça a mordu quoi et les gens
m'ont dit que il trouvait ça coule donc
ça m'a donné envie de continuer donc là
ça c'est une bonne partie de mon
activité à côté de mes cours
tu peux décrire un peu de tous tes
activités là
du coup donc j'anime du coup la chaîne
phyloxime et puis par ailleurs je donne
cours
à l'UCLouvain donc l'Université de
Louvain à Louvain-la-Neuve
essentiellement des cours d'introduction
à l'éthique aussi à l'université
Saint-Louis en Belgique donc c'est toute
l'Université catholique mais qui n'ont
surtout de catholiques que le nom que le
C dans l'acronyme et
puis à côté de ça depuis cette année
aussi je j'ai une chronique mensuelle à
la radio publique belge RTBF la
chronique philo dans une émission qui
s'appelle déclic qui est une très très
cool émission un petit peu un repère de
voilà des des intellos du service public
voilà de la télé belge la radio belge
il y a un autre truc qui nous lisse et
que on est alors je sais pas si on peut
dire qu'on est coteur
quand l'article n'a pas encore été
publié mais on a travaillé ensemble en
tout cas sur article tu peux en parler
vite fait
est-ce que je spoil déjà le contenu de
l'article où tu avais déjà spoilé dans
une précédente vidéo non un peu parce
que je raconte un peu
je pense que ça peut intéresser
bah oui donc on a avec Martin Gibert
aussi qui a un excellent chercheur en
éthique du numérique à Montréal consolue
par ailleurs et qui était à l'origine je
pense c'est lui qui t'avait contacté
sur du coup en papier sur la question de
savoir si YouTube devrait noter ses
utilisateurs pour voilà mettre en avant
les vidéos sur le climat est un sujet
dont tu avais déjà parlé toi sur ta
chaîne et du coup voilà moi j'étais un
peu la le troisième larron un peu dur à
convaincre au début et puis
à force voilà d'avoir fait mes
objections j'ai fini par
j'ai fini par être convaincu là du truc
et je suis assez content là du papier
qu'on a soumis
après avoir le retour j'espère pas dans
trois ans et demi
c'est vrai que ça va revenir assez vite
le plus vite que le pire du ring Academy
habituel
je pense qu'on peut après cette petite
introduction moi qui ai des questions
dans le chat rapidement sur sur Maxime
je pense qu'on va pouvoir passer petit à
petit à la
discussion des vidéos donc on va
commencer comme à chaque fois par parler
des trois meilleures vidéos de Maxime
d'après la communauté de tournesol
ensuite on va parler de la meilleure
vidéo à la vidéo elle peut recommandable
d'après Maxime lui-même qui n'est pas
dans le top 3 et enfin on parlera d'une
vidéo que qui aime particulièrement
marqué Maxime mais qui n'est pas de
lui-même donc
tu fais le top en faisant monter le
suspense du bœuf
astucieux astucieux mais oui donc ça en
fait c'est la vidéo sur lequel j'ai fait
le moins de trucs puisque je me suis
entre guillemets contenté de traduire
le premier chapitre et puis des extraits
de de chapitre suivant de du coup de du
ministère
alors
pour être effectivement utile
tous les viewers sachant pas encore lire
sur les lèvres de lait
ok je suis revenu normalement
est-ce que tu comptes en toi donc tu
peux y aller
tout seul non mais du coup ouais c'est
donc j'ai traduit du coup le premier
chapitre d'un bouquin du coup de
un genre qui s'appelle un genre émergent
qui s'appelle le climat fiction et c'est
un bouquin j'étais en train de le lire
et enfin moi ce premier chapitre ça m'a
vraiment bouleversé ça m'a vraiment mis
une énorme claque et ça raconte sans
trop spoiler mais un événement
climatique extrême en l'occurrence une
vague de chaleur avec des taux
d'humidité approchant les 100% etc donc
inhospitalière complètement à la
présence humaine mais complètement
mortelle en Inde du coup et ben voilà
j'ai du ça en juillet
2022 durant une des nombreuses vagues de
chaleur de l'été
du coup je me suis dit que voilà je
l'avais fait une petite
traduction alors illustrée avec avec une
IA on en parlera peut-être mis Johnny
mais ouais parce que en gros enfin ça
fait aussi partie un peu d'une réflexion
que j'ai sur
le rôle de la fiction aussi et
l'importance que la fiction peut avoir
dans la communication et la
vulgarisation des enjeux notamment sur
le climat
parce qu'à la base je crois que comme
tout bon philosophe j'étais assez
hostile à tout ce qui était storytelling
en tout cas mélange de silence et
storytelling etc tu vois c'est Platon
contre les sophistes Platon contre les
poètes etc mais est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas en train de tordre la vérité
en y mettant les formes et en y mettant
le style etc en tordant le plus souvent
parce que dans
ma thèse aussi j'avais pas mal d'auteurs
américains tu vois genre les SIG très un
fondateur des collectif quand même ou
bol ou etc qui sont en fait des auteurs
qui font à la fin prendre des bouquins
qui sont un peu académiques mais grand
public quoi et du coup chaque chapitre
c'était storytelling donc au début de
chapitre ça commençait par oui j'étais à
San Francisco à une conférence en 1992
etc et puis et du coup moi j'en pouvais
plus parce que quand elle est en mode
voilà chercheur et tout et leur former
certaines fois en plus de philosophie
contemporaine tout ça tu veux le tu veux
les arguments abstraits tu veux les
arguments précis et tout ça te paraît
complètement 20 complètement agaçant
donc donc ouais j'étais un peu hostile à
ça et puis j'ai été j'ai commencé à me
m'y intéresser en m'intéressant à la
vulgarisation comme toi moi j'ai pas été
formé pour faire de vulgarisation et
donc j'ai commencé à avoir un peu
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
communiquer sur des trucs de philo
autrement qu'en disant ben voilà il y a
l'argument 1 objection 2 objection 3 etc
l'argument 2 peut-être du patata en
énumérant des trucs quoi qui
de parler de philo même si on rajoute
des blagues et des gifs et des extraits
du Dîner de cons que sais-je mais et du
coup ouais j'ai commencé à m'intéresser
un peu à ça et à me rendre compte que
justement en fait je devais faire
l'opposé de ce que j'avais tendance à
faire quoi c'est à dire l'opposé de
juste me contenter de donner des
arguments abstraits philosophiques
qui sont tu vois bien ciselés mais du
coup tout est en tout est dit en
quelques phrases mais à la place
j'essaye de voilà je donne du corps et
du contexte avec des exemples
hypothétiques avec des voilà des petits
moments des petits passages de fiction
etc
et donc ça c'est aussi un petit peu ça
surtout aussi dans la vidéo zoopolis un
petit peu qui est un peu aussi un qui
développe aussi pas mal l'idée de
de donc sur l'éthique animal qui est
allé la voir elle est très bien aussi je
place mes produits mais c'est pas
vraiment pour ça mais du coup l'idée
c'est vraiment aussi de dire que les
arguments moraux philosophiques en soi
c'est peut-être pas sûr que ça
convaincre grand monde
en tant que tel quoi et donc en fait il
faut aussi travailler sur l'imagination
morale quoi il faut travailler sur
essayer de imaginer des histoires dans
lesquelles
voilà on arriverait à lutter contre le
richement climatique et on arriverait à
faire une transition écologique ou au
contraire on n'y arrive pas et les
conséquences de tout ça même chose
exopolis imaginons un peu qu'est-ce que
ce serait une société
non spéciste qui connaîtrait trois
animaux et pour ouais pour donner un peu
le corps à ces intuitions et donc
donc ouais je pense que c'est quelque
chose enfin j'apprends encore totalement
tous ces trucs là et du coup ouais c'est
pour ça que j'avais envie d'un petit peu
de d'avoir un passage vraiment une vidéo
de fiction sur sur ma chaîne quoi
j'ai plein de questions
la première c'est
mais du coup la fiction est quand même
utilisée un peu en philosophie enfin je
pense par exemple à la fable du dragon
tyran ou il y a quand même des histoires
du coup tu en penses quoi c'est
oui mais alors c'est aussi peut-être un
certain style de philosophie
effectivement plus
international ou analytique même si je
ne reconnaît pas vraiment exactement
dans ce dans la philo analytique mais
qui va plus se focaliser sur les
arguments
que sur le style et que sur l'histoire
ou les liens qui a littérature etc etc
mais c'est vrai que par exemple un cas
et même ça en philo international on va
dire en philo moral et tout ça c'est
l'expérience de pensée quoi qu'il a sont
effectivement des exemples mais qui sont
utilisés comme dispositif pour
réfléchir à telle ou tel intuition quoi
donc c'est quand même un peu pour
pousser un argument et d'ailleurs
souvent c'est tellement farfelu et
tellement irréaliste que ça n'aide pas
vraiment à imaginer
des conclusions ou un monde etc c'est
vraiment juste au service de l'argument
quoi
ouvre sur une fiction très bref
je sais plus qui avait eu l'idée pas moi
je pense mais en tout cas oui je trouve
ça hyper important ouais de de donner un
peu de donner un peu de contexte quoi tu
arrives et tu es pas directement dans un
truc de débat hyper abstrait mais on te
on te met graduellement en fait on te
donne quand on donne une histoire on te
enfin apparemment il y a tout un truc
aussi ça c'est les Américains sont hyper
hyper branché là dessus c'est aussi un
peu le style tête tout ça et nous
peut-être européen on a tendance à voir
ça un petit peu de haut genre oui
storytelling n'est-ce pas mais que
semble-t-il le
la capacité de mettre les
les arguments les faits en récit c'est
hyper important
bon apparemment ça a un effet sur la
production de l'ocytocine l'oxytocine
qui serait associée à des émotions
positives bon ça j'en sais rien j'y
connais rien
donc mais en tout cas ça c'est ce qui
permettrait ce qui aurait permis depuis
longtemps en tout cas aux humains de
communiquer tout un tas de faits
peut-être autour du feu ou je sais pas
comment ça a commencé quoi d'une manière
qui en fait
soit intéressant quoi et c'est le
meilleur façon effectivement de de
captiver
son audience et c'est de donner du
contexte donner pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut s'intéresser à ça pourquoi est-ce
que quels sont les accords qui dit qui
dit ah qui dit B et pourquoi c'est
important qui est en désaccord entre A
et B et du coup c'est là qu'on va avoir
envie de se dire mais en fait B a
complètement tort et pas si on commence
juste en ignorant des abonnements
philosophiques
j'ai envie de dire qu'il y a peut-être
deux objectifs un petit peu distincts le
premier ça serait de clarifier le
deuxième de convaincre et
et
que beaucoup de chercheurs pensent que
ça sert juste à convaincre et pas à
clarifier alors qu'en fait en pratique
ça sert aussi avec clarifier enfin
notamment je pense que la vidéo en
question clarifie les risques d'une
vraie d'une énorme canicule surtout dans
un pays peu développé
oui tout à fait et d'autres articles par
contre
là c'est plus une expérience de pensée
pour clarifier la rumeur en gros une
analogie avec une gigantesque
bibliothèque d'Alexandrie dans laquelle
toutes les connaissances humaines se
trouvent etc et puis il y aurait un
bibliothécaire qui serait responsable de
mettre en avant sur une étagère
euh les les livres les plus
voilà quels livres justement voilà
j'imagine que vous voyez un peu le
parallèle mais donc c'est un petit peu
ça alors oui
le il y a vraiment tout quoi il y a
clarifier il y a convaincre et il y a
aussi donné de l'intérêt et en fait
enfin c'est essentiel pour une
obligation
au début
ça fait comme malheureusement beaucoup
de conférences académiques où tout le
monde vient avec son ordi portable et
tout le monde est en train de faire ses
mails
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie non
je suis coupable à la fois des deux
d'avoir fait des conférences chiantes et
d'avoir la volonté mes mails mais parce
que ouais voilà on n'a pas cette souvent
effectivement ce réflexe dans le monde
de la recherche on n'a pas souvent en
tout cas d'essayer de d'installer de
l'intérêt y compris à ceux qui sont pas
déjà hyper spécialisés dans dans ta vie
académique quoi
c'est essentiel sinon il y a rien qui
communique quoi
du coup
ma deuxième question mais il y a le feu
chez toi c'est vrai tu as pas besoin
d'évacuer
pourquoi ça tu dis il y a le feu chez
toi là tu as pas besoin
d'évacuergétique à côté d'un très
mauvais VELUX donc voilà quand je tourne
mes vidéos dans ce genre de cas c'est le
moment de faire une pause
[Musique]
une remarque comme on en a beaucoup dans
les conférences
c'est plus sur
enfin c'est une question qu'on a souvent
sur tournesol c'est est-ce que tournesol
c'est juste
de l'information quoi ou des vidéos de
vulgarisation et en fait ce que ce que
bon score de cette vidéo ce que ça
montre c'est que non d'une certaine
manière la fiction est importante et en
fait et peut être plus efficace encore
et plus recommandable que un contenu
très très correct mais bon un peu moins
un peu moins captivant
j'étais surpris d'ailleurs que cette
vidéo soit troisième dans mon dans mon
top perso sur tournesol
j'aurais pas pensé effectivement et que
qu'elle soit parmi les plus recommandées
mais donc ouais c'est effectivement et
je sais pas si vous avez beaucoup
d'autres trucs de fiction qui qui vient
à l'esprit assez c'est une vidéo je sais
plus comment s'appelle et c'est une
humoriste anglophone qui
genre on voit ou en mec quelque chose
comme ça en mai 2020
faisait comme si elle revenait parler à
elle du passé de février 2020
et du coup avec tout ce jeu de
en février 2020 et en train de dire du
genre ah mais ce qui se passe en
Australie avec ses feux c'est genre
l'événement de l'année on va parler que
de ça pendant 10 années et en fait bah
non c'est devenu un peu c'est un peu
disparu à cause du covid
que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle climat
Adam qui est un vulgarisateur
britannique qui du coup a l'habitude de
faire des petites scènes alors il est
beaucoup bien meilleur vidéaste que moi
parce que du coup il s'est filmé sous
plein dedans différents et tout alors il
fait plusieurs personnages un truc
classique et illustre des arguments à la
con sur le climat
du genre
il est trop tard etc voilà le
réchauffement climatique est déjà en
cours on peut plus rien faire etc
j'imagine un mec qui est en train de se
faire baffer dans la rue par un malin
n'est ce pas et alors quand je lui
dirait mais non c'est trop tard le
giflage est déjà en cours
raconter comme ça c'est très nul mais
dans le dans ces vidéos ça donne
vraiment un plus parce que ça fait des
trucs mémorables aussi quoi plus que des
banques comme ça aride d'un argument et
sinon ma dernière vidéo ouvre sur une
fiction
très réaliste mais
une vision quand même et
je pense que c'est important et surtout
en fait derrière la fiction il y a
souvent beaucoup de messages et parfois
des messages aussi de propagande donc je
pense notamment
à chaque fois qu'il y a un film
américain sur la guerre du Vietnam bah
bizarrement c'est on parle d'un héros
américain qui défendent sa patrie alors
qu'on pourrait facilement tourner
l'histoire de toute façon complètement
différente et si on regarde un
documentaire souvent les tournées de
toute façon très différente
de façon similaire en Chine et d'autant
plus de fiction qui montre les héros
chinois qui se battent contre les forces
occidentales
et en fait je réfléchis toi mais je
pense enfin il y a plein de trucs dans
nos cultures politiques et dans nos
systèmes
qui sont en fait basés sur un autorité
ligne quoi le le mythe de la
méritocratie du self-medman
tous les milliardaires vont vous
raconter une histoire voilà qu'ils ont
commencé dans leur garage ou non je ne
sais pas quoi bon je sais pas comment
muscle arrive à s'en sortir mais
j'imagine qu'il essaie de s'en sortir
mais avec son père propriétaire de
émeraude
Afrique du Sud ou apartheid c'est quand
même un peu plus difficile mais bon
voilà c'est quand même un truc très fort
et c'est du storytelling qui est
derrière tout ça et qui permet qui fait
que
super transition vers ma troisième
question c'est c'est que donc il y a 4
GPT qui est sorti récemment qui produit
beaucoup de textes et Hayden donc le
secrétaire de l'association tournesol
donc un des grands contributeurs de
tournesol la violence sur la phrase
raconte moi la
l'épopée ou la vie de dédier Raoult
et j'ai pété trois open GPT a commencé à
raconter enfin tu as déjà pété a
commencé à raconter l'histoire de
quelqu'un qui s'est battu contre qui a
persévéré qui a trouvé le médicament
miracle contre la vie de la communauté
le truc
qui pose problème c'est la fiction mais
c'est de la fiction très problématique
donc ça ça m'amène à parler à la
troisième question qui est plus sur
enfin tout le mentionner un peu
rapidement c'est cette image
ces illustrations que tu utilises tout
au long de cette vidéo tu peux en parler
oui j'ai utilisé un logiciel qui
s'appelle le midjoni que j'ai découvert
plus ou moins au moment où ça sortait là
en juin etc je me suis enfin je trouvais
ça hyper hyper intrigant et j'ai
l'impression qu'il se passait vraiment
des des trucs là-dessus alors moi j'ai
un petit enfin j'aime bien je m'amuse
avec Photoshop quoi on va dire c'est mes
talents de
c'est mon niveau graphisme c'est pas
plus du tout mais voilà j'aimerais bien
avoir un peu du temps à apprendre ça
aussi et illustration et tout ça et mais
j'ai enfin du coup moi ça me ça
m'a bluffé
mais déjà en juin la qualité de ces
trucs et puis le truc c'est que depuis
effectivement quasi tous les mois il y a
une nouvelle version avec voilà des
niveaux de résultats assez assez
impressionnant et en même temps voilà je
me souviens longtemps posé la question
de comment on en parlait quoi est-ce que
est-ce que j'utilise ça dans mes vidéos
est-ce que je est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut mettre en avant
et notamment l'impression effectivement
de participer un peu à une forme de
alors ce serait pas ubérisation mais de
d'obsolescence de certains métiers
artistiques alors je pense pas que ce
sera le cas je pense que comme enfin
c'est ce qu'on dit souvent mais comme
souvent Jean du truc ce sera plus un
outil comme actuellement sous Photoshop
vous avez le contacter le film vous avez
tout un tas de trucs qui sont assistés
paria sera un outil utilisé par les
graphistes pour
voilà continuer à développer des trucs
créatifs tout ça mais c'est clair que je
sais plus il y avait eu un journal
est-ce que c'est pas le meilleur
postes
qui avait
au magazine qui avait du coup utilisé
pour un drapeau illustrer un article
Unia quoi plutôt que d'habitude
typiquement c'est le genre de
de médias qui Harcourt au service de
graphiste et tout ça et
là où bon voilà nous
les youtubeurs j'ai envie de dire on est
un peu enfin
la raison d'être et la raison pour
laquelle on est là sur Youtube alors je
sais pas si vous m'entendez toujours
mais en tout cas les a disparu je
continue comme si de rien n'était
la raison pour laquelle nous on est ça
va
on a du matériel du petit matos des
webcams des appareils photos numériques
des petits micros comme celui-ci etc qui
peuvent qu'on peut gérer tout seul et
qui permettent de se passer de d'une
équipe de caméraman d'une équipe de
preneurs de son etc tout un tas de
métiers et perd on a des logiciels qui
permettent de faire un peu voilà un
certain montage qui permettent de pour
certains de se passer du recours à un
monteur professionnel donc c'est déjà un
peu un peu ça qu'on fait
et donc de toute façon je ne gagne pas
ma vie avec Youtube ou encore donc je
moi-même je sais pas vraiment minerai
donc j'aurais bien du mal à rémunérer un
graphiste mais ça pose quand même
question quoi ces trucs là
donc voilà je sais pas toi ce que tu ce
que tu en ce que tu en penses
la première c'est que les illustrations
enfin c'est un métier qui est
illustration illustrateur scientifique
aussi notamment tout ce qui est en
astronomie
beaucoup est dessiné et
en fait c'est ce que l'astronomie c'est
un peu le
c'est un peu la science la plus
populaire j'ai l'impression enfin des
sciences c'est plus populaire grand
public et je pense que
les illustrations ils font beaucoup
mais
en philosophie ça peut être difficile
d'illustrer les choses en mathématiques
aussi et en fait ça apporte énormément
que de pouvoir mettre une image surtout
un peu jolie
c'est pas ça permet de capter attention
enfin c'est même raison que le
storytelling quoi
donc il y aura un vrai intérêt
pédagogique et de vulgarisation à
utiliser ces images tout à fait moi
c'est vraiment enfin oui c'est
effectivement un truc
des raisons de mon intérêt pour tout ça
c'est vrai comment est-ce que tu comment
est-ce que tu illustres la justice
l'équité la justice intergénérationnelle
l'éthique animale ce genre de trucs en
tout un tas de concepts hyper abstraits
vous pouvez regarder sur Google alors
vous surtout les banques d'image ou de
vidéos de stock qu'on a voilà on a
vraiment rien de très pollution pour
pour illustrer ça quoi alors
effectivement là ce genre de ce genre de
système permet de ouais de sortir des
trucs en fait qui sont assez créatifs et
qui évoque effectivement ses idées et
qui peut qui moi enfin moi c'est quelque
chose que j'ai trouvé vraiment
hyper attirant comment effectivement
illustrer des concepts philosophes
après l'autre l'autre pendant
moi j'étais enceinte très critique de
tous les toutes les avancées en IA
notamment pour raconter une anecdote
j'étais un truc qui organisé par
facebook sur l'application
d'intelligence artificielle en
mathématiques et des trucs vraiment
incroyable il y avait des enfin ça aide
à vraiment démontrer rigoureusement des
nous soit des nouveautés théorèmes soit
des théorèmes dont on avait déjà la
preuve mais moi ça fait une preuve
formelle vérifiée par ordinateur et donc
il y a plein de progrès vraiment
spectaculaire et fascinant c'est facile
de s'émerveiller de devant mais le
pendant de la chose c'est que du coup on
associe l'IA quelque chose de positif à
quelque chose de et donc je posais la
question à cette conférence à tous les
chercheurs mais déjà qui finance cette
conférence et pourquoi
[Musique]
beaucoup de
modèles d'affaires loin de voir de
métier
et ça on l'observe YouTube bouleversé
toutes les chaînes télé enfin forcément
fait beaucoup de changements partout
quoi
parce que il y a une question dans le
chat qui dit est-ce que
sur évalue pas le rôle des IA artistes
en fait je pense que on s'en rend pas
compte mais elles sont déjà vraiment
[Musique]
dans beaucoup d'endroits quoi il y a
beaucoup enfin rien que là quand je
stream là il y a un fond vert qui est
derrière moi qui qui enfin j'utilise
déjà des technologies assez basiques
mais voilà dans un an ou deux bah là il
y aura peut-être un truc mieux qui qui
sera utilisé ça fera une meilleure image
et tout ça et donc on utilise ces outils
pour produire du contenu et puis les
artistes utilisent ça pour produire
leur contenu aussi donc ça ça déjà
révolutionné on prend l'industrie
cinématographique par exemple il y a
beaucoup de technologies de partout
maintenant utiliser pour pour faire des
images
je pense que
faut pas sous-estimer effectivement
là-bas tu peux avoir ce genre de trucs
et effectivement les problèmes je vois
dans le traite effectivement il y a le
problème éthique des artistes dont les
travaux ont été
voilà utilisés Data Miner pour pour
créer les modèles
souvent j'ai l'impression pour le moment
un petit peu en mode Far West et non pas
uniquement des travaux sous licencie etc
etc et avec des donc ça donne avec
certains modèles ouais des des modèles
ou
on les créateurs du coup du modèle ont
dû enlever certains noms de créateurs ou
certains comme Greg
ruthovski qui était devenu apparemment
une
voilà un référence incontournable parce
que les gens se rendent compte comme
étant son nom ça donnait des tableaux
fantastique etc
mais donc ouais il y a tous ces
problèmes là il y a les problèmes qui se
posent aussi pour les générateurs
type gbd3
qui est les problèmes de billets
ethniques de billets en tout genre que
ça peut avoir et puis enfin les
questions aussi que ça posera à l'avenir
c'est enfin et déjà maintenant enfin les
possibilités de Deep fake est-ce qu'on
pourra se fier à une quelconque images
sur internet
je pense pas je pense que on va arriver
à une époque où il faut considérer les
images même photo réalistes comme une
forme de portrait comme une forme de
tableau
et
une représentation forcément
artificielle ou avec un immense en
créative du monde mais
je crois qu'il faudrait sortir de cette
idée que la photo c'est c'est le miroir
de la réalité quoi
ça va être très compliqué enfin de
tendance des domaines comme je pense par
exemple
ce qui est reportage sur les crimes de
guerre ils essaient de monter des
dossiers et tout ça donc forcément à la
fin du contenu photographié ou des
témoignages ou genre de choses mais la
facilité de produire ces mêmes contenus
ça va compliquer beaucoup la faire
au final un des aspects qui va permettre
de d'atténuer ces problèmes c'est le
fait de faire confiance à des
journalistes
mais je sais pas si
est-ce que c'est moi qui ne suis plus
sur le feed ou est-ce que c'est les
je t'entends plus
il y a un truc qui frise
[Musique]
alors
maxime a disparu
j'espère qu'il va revenir
on va remercier les opérateurs
télécommunications belges pour ce stream
voilà je suis de retour apparemment il y
a eu un petit bug
je te
les produits live ça recouper je
t'entends plus à nouveau
mais tu ne m'entends pas
allô
[Musique]
étrange
quand on taper sur le clavier
[Musique]
ils ont l'air de nous entendre ben je ne
sais pas
si c'est moi qui suis
à l'antenne ou si c'est les je t'entends
mais tu m'entends pas c'est ça
le live mais je le vois pas dans la
conversation
ok
on est complètement tordu parce que du
coup il y a un décalage de 10 secondes
et du coup je
OK
conversation idéale voilà ça
prochaine fois je prends de mon
Marrakech
peut-être passer à la deuxième vidéo je
pense qu'on a fait depuis une demi-heure
sur scène c'est pas censé être aussi
long
on va passer à la deuxième vidéo
[Musique]
alors qui est donc la vidéo les
eucogestes sont-ils futiles
un petit peu ou que je parle un peu la
vidéo
les deux
ouais pardon je t'entends de manière un
petit peu juré donc du coup je vais
supposer
la question mais donc ouais ça c'est une
vidéo sur un voilà un sujet qui qui
anime beaucoup les réseaux sociaux et
enfin comme beaucoup de peut-être de
sujets de vidéos ça j'ai vu pas mal de
trucs un peu excessifs là dessus
et ça m'a donné envie de faire une vidéo
quoi de
entre la critique tout à fait légitime
de
du détournement d'attention par les
grands entreprises qui appellent les
consommateurs à faire des petits efforts
etc voir parler gouvernements je repense
à la déclaration de je crois que c'était
Barbara Pompidou quand elle était
ministre de la transition énergétique
qui répondait à une des membres la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
lui parlait de questions de réforme
politique publique et elle lui répondait
oui alors comment c'est déjà par trio
boîte mail ce sera déjà pas mal
donc voilà donc une critique tout tout à
fait légitime de
l'insistance qu'on a parfois sur ces
éco-gestes on est passé à un moment à un
truc genre ouais les efforts visuels ça
sert complètement à rien voilà il y a
que l'action que collective qui compte
et voilà en gros autant qu'on aura pas
fait la révolution
ça sert à rien de penser à essayer de de
faire quoi que ce soit et puis tout un
tas d'affirmations aussi je trouve qui
est un petit peu
tiré de
mon petit doigt m'a dit
un peu sur ces sujets par exemple
est-ce que les éco-gestes sont
contre-productifs
pour par exemple mener les gens à
l'engagement politique est-ce que au
contraire c'est un impact positif neutre
et tout ça bah alors dans un sujet
systématiquement vous avez les gens qui
sont là amenés moi je suis sûr avec des
avis hyper tranchés non non c'est contre
mon objectif d'ailleurs regardez ma
belle-soeur
et et on voit aussi encore récemment la
vue pour les questions de est-ce que les
techniques de licence civiles en mode
just stop all de jet de sauce tomate sur
des tableaux de purée de pommes de terre
etc est-ce que ça aussi c'était
utile ou contre-productif etc et là
aussi j'ai été frappé de voir que tout
le monde a son petit avis mais y compris
des autorités de scientifiques disons
mais basé sur rien en fait pas basé sur
oui c'est mon petit avis quoi et donc
après c'est très bien on a tout le monde
a droit à la façon quittavie mais moi je
trouve justement quand on fait la
vulgarisation ou la communication
scientifique validée c'est justement
d'essayer d'informer ce genre de débat
et de dire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut tirer comme
conclusion que dit la littérature
aujourd'hui
et donc et puis
donc du coup je couvre un petit peu
ouais une littérature sur est-ce que
est-ce que vraiment il y a une
opposition pouvoir faire est-ce que les
petits gestes poussent à l'engagement
politique ou au contraire est-ce que
c'est une distraction qui fait peur de
l'énergie etc qui serait du coup
contre-productif pour l'engagement
politique qui est effectivement
indispensable
et puis parler aussi un peu désordres de
grandeur c'était un petit peu évidemment
le
rapport carbone 4 le fameux truc etc qui
disait que les efforts des efforts
individuels d'un niveau qu'ils
appelaient héroïque bon je trouve ça un
peu excessif de parler des reliques mais
bon
ça va permettrait quand même de baisser
de 45% je pense les les émissions
l'empreinte carbone d'un Français moyen
sachant que c'était les efforts
plus les investissements
etc etc mais donc c'est pas suffisant
puisqu'il restait genre 35% qui
dépendent de réforme systémiques qui
sont liés au système industriel au
service public etc et donc voilà
discuter un petit peu tout ça discuter
faire le lien aussi entre avec la
distinction dont on parle souvent dans
les vidéos sur l'éthique entre
conséquentialiste et déontologie
avec cette idée de ouais du Colibri
déontologiste qui fait les choses parce
que c'est la bonne chose à faire et
voilà c'est comme ça et je moi au moins
je suis à l'aise avec ma conscience et
le colibri conséquentialiste qui se
préoccupe plus de l'impact réel de des
efforts qui fait et essayer de faire
vraiment de dépenser de l'énergie là où
c'est vraiment utile quoi et il y avait
notamment une étude
Ipsos un sondage Ipsos qui était je
pense dans une des dernières vidéos de
chez Anatole ou on demandait un peu aux
gens c'est quoi pour vous les gestes qui
ont un impact qui ont plus d'impact sur
le climat puis les gens cité toujours
les trucs les plus anecdotiques en
premier quand
recycler recycler ses déchets qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait remplacé ces ampoules dans
les dans les premières places alors que
c'était effectivement je pensais
etc et par contre il sous-estimer
complètement les efforts dans le
transport en voiture ils te font l'avion
et bien sûr le fait de passer à un
régime végétal ou végétarien
donc voilà ça c'est tous des trucs
qui me paraissaient important un petit
peu de ouais de clarifier et
de temps de montrer que c'est un faux
dilemme quoi et que bien sûr
on n'est pas forcément obligé de choisir
absolument l'un ou l'autre et d'être un
militant du climat qui prend l'avion
tous les week-ends
le zéro déchet je fais mes shampoing
moi-même etc et je me suis
reclus du reste du monde
est complètement coupé de du reste quoi
donc voilà c'était un petit peu le
un petit peu le pitch de cette vidéo et
ouais ça m'a pas oui ça m'a pas étonné
de l'avoir par contre si c'est bien
classé sur tournesol parce que c'est un
débat qui malheureusement pas clôturer
le débat
on aimerait bien à chaque fois
et les débats un petit peu caricaturaux
sur
les cogettes sur son collectif
[Musique]
le côté les gens s'acharnent sur une
question empirique sans donner c'est
assez frustrant surtout quand c'est
donné
j'ai pas entendu la fin de ton mais je
suis d'accord c'est très frustrant
je suis
une question c'est est-ce que tu savais
tout ça au moment où tu as décidé de
faire cette vidéo ou est-ce que tu as
découvert en vidéo
tu m'entends
du coup tu m'entends
pas tu me vois mais tu m'entends
[Musique]
on peut faire ça
ou alors je mets des écouteurs et je
t'écoute juste sur Youtube je ne sais
pas moi
sur l'écran sur sur Youtube ok peut-être
que ça peut réduire un petit peu et en
fait je peux aussi ne pas t'envoyer ma
vidéo
comme ça
ok
donc
ma question c'était est-ce que
toutes ces données justement ces études
empiriques tu les connaissais au moment
où tu as décidé de commencer faire cette
vidéo ou tu as découvert en faisant
non non j'ai découvert en faisant la
vidéo
j'ai vraiment farfouillé
il y avait quelques auteurs que je
connaissais dont une autre espèce
Juliette score qui travaille sur
la consommation responsable etc qui
chercheuse à Boston qui est très
chouette
et puis mais voilà mais j'ai vraiment
fait le tour et puis je me suis
renseigné un petit peu en demandant aux
auteurs d'une des études
si vraiment enfin il y avait vraiment
que quatre études je sujet et
effectivement et avec
d'après lui aussi voilà il avait
s'identifier que quatre études
empiriques donc on est vraiment dans un
truc hyper voilà un peu balbutiement de
de cette question et de cette du coup
discussion empirique c'est pour ça aussi
que dans la dans la vidéo je termine en
disant que voilà les conclusions qu'on
peut donner sont doivent rester très
modeste parce que
trois études qui montrent une
corrélation positive voilà c'est pas
c'est pas le fin mot de l'histoire
sur quatre études on tendance à trouver
une correction plutôt positive que
négative
donc ça ça devrait calmer un peu ceux
qui ont des avis tranchés sur forcément
l'un ou l'autre
c'est ça une hypothèse neutre et trois
une corrélation positive
dont une solitude
avec une étudiante
donc voilà donc en tout cas
c'était une vidéo et puis alors surtout
je me suis beaucoup pris la tête à me
filmer à jeter des pots de yaourt dans
ma poubelle donc voilà je vous pourrez
enfin voilà aller la voir pour pour ça
et puis il y a un bêtisier quelque part
aussi
j'ai dû jeter à peu près une
cinquantaine de fois des bouillir dans
ma poubelle bref
est-ce que tu as d'autres choses à
rajouter sur cette vidéo on peut passer
à la comparaison
oui on peut ah oui c'est ça c'est le
moment où tu me demandes de comparer mes
enfants c'est ça
[Rires]
alors
oui j'ai un clavier très bruyant
du mécanique mais du coup
si les gens veulent faire
copier coller
j'arrive pas à faire copier coller dans
Obs je sais pas pourquoi mais
c'est pas grave
non dans le château
pour pour communiquer non
tout à l'heure mais
entre nous
donc bon tu vas à l'écran à gauche c'est
ta vidéo la grande canicule
à droite ta vidéo sur les éco-gestes je
vois ça sur
quel tu recommandes de plus à gauche ou
à droite
devrait être largement recommandé
ça dépend ça dépend à qui ceux qui sont
dans les polémiques
un peu caca sur Twitter plutôt celle de
droite mais j'imagine que je n'ai pas le
droit de faire une réponse comme ça
je mettrai quand même
plus peut-être un cran vers la droite
mais sachant que je recommande assez
vivement le bouquin mais ça va le futur
mais bon après voilà ma contribution en
l'occurrence et la vidéo par rapport au
bouquin
voilà j'ai peut-être une moins grande
contribution certainement il manque
entre le contribution de la vidéo de
gauche que dans la vidéo sur les
éco-gestes quoi
ok bah accro à droite en plus dans les
détails
du coup laquelle est plus fiable et non
trompeuse
alors
a priori je pense que
Robinson c'est plutôt un auteur je crois
que il est plutôt bien renseigné etc bon
après si on a
un a priori négatif sur la fiction
peut-être qu'on pourrait dire que la
fiction est toujours un petit peu
davantage
[Musique]
pose des risques de d'être davantage
trompeur trompeuse etc
je mettrai je mettrai au milieu je pense
que Robinson a fait très bien son
travail donc
de la fiction bien renseignée
pédagogique
alors là je mettrai ça plus dans la
vidéo qui est davantage effectivement
une vidéo de vulga donc
je sais pas
3 il y a combien de Crans du coup trois
quatre ans
au total
ah oui je peux cliquer sur le lien je
viens de découvrir pardon ouais ouais
bah oui c'est ça
hop ils ont disons quatre crans à droite
je te fais des fleurs parce que de
nouveau l'autre
illustré et qu'il a lu ce que tu les lui
de façon claire
oui forcément l'aspect pédagogique et
évidemment moins
important et actionnaire
ouais très nettement celle de gauche
après les questions de comment résoudre
et quand j'ai reçu un collective c'est
important mais
ouais
je dirais quand même
peut-être
5 ans à gauche mais alors actionnable
c'était c'est quoi encore c'est que ça
suscite à l'action que on peut en faire
quelque chose que c'est
important oui alors ça dépend si on
s'arrête mais c'est pas ce que si on
s'arrête au premier chapitre c'est
plutôt déprimant et donc ça suffit
surtout des espoirs et c'est pour ça que
j'ai rajouté
j'ai rajouté un extrait d'un des
chapitres suivants qui étaient quand
même plus plus optimiste
malgré tout donc ouais je mettrais
à gauche ok c'est un cran à gauche
après c'est difficile parce que voilà
j'ai
excessive non spécialiste
là on peut mettre je sais pas moi oui
divertissant et relaxant
c'est vrai que les deux sont toujours
associés
[Rires]
ouais c'est ça dans les deux on voit
d'ailleurs des flammes là et un truc un
peu apocalyptique
je fais il y a des blagues avec des
yaourts donc c'est un peu divertissant
donc peut-être trois grands à droite
c'est quand même une histoire c'est
ouais mais
que je qualifierai ni de relaxante ni de
divertissante je vous conseille quand
même d'aller la voir
stimulant et suscite la réflexion
ouais ça
peut-être un petit peu plus celle de
droite parce que nouveau dans celle de
gauche ouais il y a la réflexion plus
expliqué moins présente peut-être deux
grands à droite de grande
diversité et inclusion
alors tu me rappelles c'est quoi le
secrétaire là est-ce que ça promet la
diversité et ça parle un peu à tout le
monde est-ce que ça inclut aussi
[Musique]
sorte de personnes
voir d'animaux voire de voilà ce que
c'est permet d'avoir une pensée
inclusive sur sur le monde
disons
c'est une préoccupation que j'ai eu dans
les deux vidéos
par exemple dans la vidéo sur les
ecogènes
normalement quand vous voyez un peu des
images avec des différentes personnes je
sais qui qui
aussi souvent des femmes que des hommes
etc enfin plus ou moins etc je sais pas
si c'est vraiment si ça aide beaucoup à
l'inclusion mais voilà j'essaie de pas
avoir des trucs trop
masculos centré
après non je mettrai quand même assez
plutôt avec trois crans à gauche pour
même cinq rangs à gauche pour le
ministère du futur puisque on parle de
de pays en développement qui vont être
les plus touchés et sont déjà les plus
touchés par Lachance
sur le site climatique je pense que
beaucoup plus sensibilisé au sort de
deux personnes beaucoup plus exposées à
ces problèmes de canicule que
en Europe
encourage de meilleures habitudes
alors là
[Musique]
sans doute
est-ce que ça encourage je sais pas si
j'encourage oui bah peut-être un petit
peu son ou celle de droite mais
j'encourage pas
on pourrait dire disons le truc auquel
j'encourage c'est peut-être
d'être si vous êtes un colibri d'être un
colibri plutôt conséquentiste ça c'est
quand même d'être un petit peu mon biais
et de faire attention à l'impact que que
vous avez quoi donc
ouais peut-être trois grands à droite
et enfin résistant au retour négatif
donc il y a des gens réfractaires qui
regardent la vidéo
à quel point est-ce que la vidéo
empêche le fait qu'il se braque
[Musique]
alors j'ai eu des retours j'ai eu des
retours négatifs pour la vidéo mystère
du futur en raison de la fin un peu plus
optimiste
que voilà on est tous foutu et que
il n'est rien permis d'espérer de voilà
un petit peu
encourageant donc peut-être que
paradoxalement voilà c'est on est
tellement dans un truc
déprimant et avec parfois dans son
domisme et tout ça que que
les commentaires mais que oui
un truc un petit peu avec une fin un peu
encourageant que peut être considéré
comme utopique donc peut-être un petit
peu plus celle de celle de droite mais
ouais c'est ça je sais pas moi c'est
difficile de jeter des fleurs comme ça
peut-être
ouais peut-être trois quand même parce
que après on peut toujours en désaccord
et plein de trucs qui sont dit dans la
vidéo mais effectivement le point qui
est que
il faut essayer d'un petit peu fonder
ses arguments dans des sur des bases
dans les bases empiriques et pas juste
ce que son petit doigt vous dit
voilà ça ça amène quand même une forme
de débat peut-être un peu différente
la fiction que j'ai écrit Smart pop avec
l'escale face et ça finit de façon très
positive
ça me paraît assez utopiste mais bon
négatif je peux beaucoup de retours et
en tout cas pas négatif sur le fait que
ça finisse bien oui c'est difficile ça a
un bouquin il y a un truc extrêmement
entre guillemets injuste avec quand les
youtubeurs c'est que nous à chaque fois
qu'on sort une vidéo on a des montagnes
de feedback et des et des te rendes
compliments la plupart du temps quand
même il y a pas que des trolls et alors
que
Dupont un livre une BD ou que sais-je
jamais autant de retour quoi donc ouais
marcher
en auto-édition c'était un peu compliqué
de trouver
des éditeurs
ok bah triangle on peut passer enfin
valider déjà
[Musique]
si tu en fais encore si on en fait 96 ce
soir on attend 60000
ou alors si les gens du chat font chacun
une comparaison je pense on est passé 60
000 ce soir il faut juste nous laisser
l'honneur de faire 60 millièmes
ok du coup on va passer à la troisième
vidéo
je vais mettre ça en place donc la
troisième vidéo non c'est pas celle-là
c'est une vidéo sur l'empathie
c'était
Ukraine notre empathie biaisée tout à
fait
tout à fait ben oui
là aussi
enfin moi c'était un sujet qui m'a
vraiment
hyper fort à coeur évidemment au début
de la crise la guerre en Ukraine
et effectivement ce traitement de faveur
enfin voilà je suis très loin d'être le
seul là vraiment marqué bien sûr
dont on pu bénéficier des réfugiés
Ukrainiens bon alors maintenant
l'enthousiasme vient un peu plus passer
parce que en tout cas en Belgique parmi
les réfugiés qui sont sans papiers etc
et aussi Ukrainiens etc c'est loin
d'être l'accueil royal mais en tout cas
voilà on a eu tout un tas de mesures qui
ont été prises notamment la gratuité
pour les transports en commun etc et des
visas d'accueil etc et
puis et donc effectivement frappant vu
la réaction qu'on a eu à la à la dite
crise migratoire qui concernait environ
un peu plus d'un million de réfugiés du
Moyen-Orient Syrie etc il y a plus de 5
ans et qui qui qui
l'a on avait genre 5 millions de
réfugiés Ukrainiens qui
a prévu en tout cas et voilà un élan
solidarité etc et donc du coup les
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
parfois même qui allaient jusqu'à
mais
critiquer ou
ça peut même les bases de cette élan de
solidarité
et
en raison de
ces différences de traitement et à
certains égards discriminatoires il y a
clairement dans pas mal de cas du
racisme mais je voulais un peu dire que
en gros mis à part clairement enfin donc
le racisme joue un rôle certainement
l'exemple des réfugiés Ukrainiens de
couleurs noir qui était qui était viré à
la frontière en Pologne etc enfin de
trucs comme ça mais ça va plus loin que
ça et je voulais un petit peu pousser à
remettre en cause aussi nos propres
bières en mode en fait il suffit pas de
même si on
résolvait
les le racisme c'est déjà pas mal des
gens vicieux
on aurait toujours ses biais d'empathie
vraisemblablement qu'on peut pas
forcément assimiler à Dieu racisme et
qui sont
qui sont qui sont en gros problème pour
des éthiques à vocation universaliste
comme la plupart des éthiques qu'ils ont
contemporaine parce que du coup
effectivement
la question qui peut se poser c'est
comment est-ce que on peut fonder des
arguments liés à la solidarité à
l'accueil de réfugiés à
enfin voilà la société des situations en
cas de guerre etc dans un sentiment
qui est très généralement biaisé en
faveur de gens qui sont comme nous entre
guillemets qui qui appartiennent au même
groupe que nous Européens etc qui ont
voilà plein de tout un tas de billets le
billet de la personne identifiable
et donc je voulais un petit peu remettre
en cause ça parce que c'est un truc
enfin les médecins un petit peu sur le
vent la scène de dire c'est pas une
question simple
ça se résume pas juste au racisme même
si c'est une composante importante
évidemment
et c'est un problème
en général pour
et
peut-être toi tu verras aussi ce genre
de problème ou de
quand on essaye quand on est une
approche normative et qu'on essaie de
d'attirer l'attention du public surtout
un tas de sur la justice à travers le
monde on se rend compte que ben oui la
tension que qu'on est prêt à accorder à
tout un tas de situations d'injustice
extrême
ailleurs dans le monde ou voilà des
communautés qui sont qui sont pas dans
la communauté nationale etc ces capacité
est très inégalement répartie quoi et
donc
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour arriver à
sensibiliser
et élargir un petit peu ce que Singer a
plein d'autres cercle de préoccupation
morale
sachant aussi que
si c'est pas forcément entièrement
justifié d'avoir certains billets et
certaines obligations spéciales je pense
vis-à-vis de sa famille de proches etc
évidemment donc
c'est un extrême il y a un genre de
cosmopolitisme ou de un utilitarisme
rationnel
universalisme qui ne reconnaîtrait aucun
engagement en particulier et aucune
aucune obligation particulière et à
l'autre extrême il y aurait une forme de
racisme de spécisme de biais
injustifiable pour ses semblables quoi
et donc ouais c'est une question
[Musique]
que je trouvais en vrai qui continue de
m'occuper beaucoup quoi comment est-ce
qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à mon
intuition évidemment qu'il faut étendre
la sphère de préoccupation morale mais
tout en sachant que
voilà il y a des limites à nos capacités
d'attention à nos capacités d'empathie
et puis alors du coup la question de
l'empathie et tout le débat qui existe
là-dessus est-ce que est-ce qu'on a
besoin de l'empathie en moral est-ce
qu'il faut se passer de l'empathie
est-ce qu'il faut des biaiser l'empathie
voilà ça c'est
c'est un peu toute la question
plein de questions
juste faire une remarque sur le fait que
le racisme
et notamment à la frontière crée une
Pelonne du beaucoup d'histoires donc pas
mal de frontières mais
pendant la guerre il y avait pas mal
d'histoires de racisme envers des
étrangers qui habitent en Pologne et qui
essaient de faire l'Ukraine pardon et
qui est cette cuire l'Ukraine et donc il
y a pas mal de récits aussi c'était une
situation très complexe
et puis l'autre question enfin remarque
c'est
le fait que
un des gros problèmes qui qui a plein de
questions philosophiques difficiles
comme tu veux dire entre les semblables
et
universalisme
l'une des difficultés qui soit c'est
aussi que
le l'empathie peut être hacké et que
suffit d'exposition informelle en fait
pour répéter
pour pouvoir biaiser enfin se sentir
plus proche avoir s'identifier davantage
à certaines communautés plutôt qu'adres
voir parfois se distancer elle pouvait
de la haine envers d'autres communautés
et donc là je pense que c'est un énorme
enjeu je pense que c'est un des enjeux
les plus importants pour éviter des
dégâts catastrophiques
comment est-ce qu'on peut
réduire les aujourd'hui
encore algorithmes de recommandations
qui je pensais je joue vraiment un rôle
central c'est que si elles amplifie à
telle communauté des images horribles de
l'autre communauté et vice-versa
ce qui est un peu ce qui est en train
d'arriver à une échelle énorme
aujourd'hui
il y a des tensions qui vont
naturellement
s'amplifier et s'exacerber et là l'autre
empathie s'est fait complètement inquiet
quoi c'est très
dangereux et sur les sur les biais de
l'empathie je disais quelque part pour
revenir sur la question la fiction que
apparemment les mécanismes fictionnels
peuvent avoir tendance à justement
augmenter les billets d'appartenance au
groupe et à mettre les gens dans un mode
alors bon voilà je
pourrais mettre la source mais je ne
sais pas du tout dans quelle mesure tout
ça effectivement en revanche du conso
scientifique et tout ça je suis pas
expert de tout ça donc voilà un gros
grain de sel mais en tout cas qui aurait
une tension quoi entre
storytelling ou fiction etc un mode
fictionnel et qui en fait poussent les
gens à se mettre dans un mode
très
d'attitude de de conformisme de groupe
et de réactions un peu viscérale
vis-à-vis des membres de leur groupe et
on revient un peu à un truc
collectiviste
qui du coup va à l'encontre d'un idéal
qui serait celui détendre la sphère de
préoccupation morale quoi
et juste sur le racisme je voulais juste
dire que dans la vidéo je suis un petit
peu plus je prends un peu plus de
pincettes évidemment et je dis je
distingue aussi différents différents
cas et bien sûr
la question du traitement des réfugiés
des obligations internationales des
États qui ne souffrent aucune
discrimination possible etc
1 et donc
les questions aussi de la responsabilité
morale des journalistes sur ces
questions là sur la façon dont ils en
parlent dans tes traitent sur
l'utilisation de migrants pour certains
quand il s'agit une Orient de réfugiés
beaucoup plus clairement quand il s'agit
d'ukrainien etc et par ailleurs
l'attitude de l'opinion publique avec
cet élan de solidarité avec les gens
qu'on voit des
des gens chez eux qui envoient des
vivres etc donc
bien distinguer ces différents niveaux
quoi le choix des images est diffusé
son bébé
et un groupe de réfugiés plus jeune
enfin
je veux pas mal à perception que pas
avoir le grand public
de ce que sont
les réfugiés
un truc que j'arrive pas non
impôt sur lequel je veux revenir c'est
un des trucs qu'on essaie de faire avec
je sais pas très bien parlé encore de
cette idée à tout le monde à tournesol
mais un des trucs que j'aimerais que
surtout une seule idée davantage c'est
que on met des collaborations avec des
groupes des organisations
donc gouvernementales par exemple à la
fois pour les questions de climat mais
également pour ces questions de droits
humains et je pense que enfin j'ai eu
l'occasion de parler avec des gens
d'amnistie France la semaine dernière et
c'est vrai que ces questions de
recommandation et tout ça est devenu
vraiment critique parce que pour pour
beaucoup de causes mais en particulier
les droits humains l'attention est
vraiment clé quoi le feu des projecteurs
sur l'Ukraine on a parlé énormément de
l'Ukraine il y a des conflits à côté
enfin par exemple en Éthiopie la plupart
des gens ignorent qu'il y a une guerre
atroce qui a causé beaucoup plus de
morts que quand Ukraine peut-être 100
fois plus
au moins 10 fois plus
un peu partout quoi mais
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un gros défi compliqué
pour quand ces institutions pour essayer
de mettre en avant des des souffrances
humaines parfois bien
il y a vraiment des des trucs horribles
d'histoire de crimes de guerre
d'histoire de viol et tout ça enfin
c'est vraiment des trucs horribles je
veux pas minimiser ce qui se passe en
Ukraine mais
il y a des choses horribles un peu
partout dans le monde et de la tension
est vraiment clé pour pouvoir résoudre
ces problèmes souvent et malheureusement
c'est difficile aujourd'hui enfin c'est
vraiment la guerre d'attention une des
victimes principales c'est tout toutes
les personnes dont les droits humains
sont bafoués et tout à fait je crois que
tu as commencé un mot important qui le
mot institution et on revient un petit
peu en fait à finalement au débat et à
la question
geste individuelle versus action
collective parce que quelque part dans
ces questions ici notamment la question
de l'accueil des réfugiés la question de
l'aide au développement la question de
des pertes préjudices pour les dégâts
causés par le climat etc du financement
de changement climatique pour les pays
du Sud c'est tout des trucs en fait sur
lesquels on
devrait pouvoir développer des réponses
collectives
et qui sont du coup institutionnalisés
qui qui sont créés au niveau des États
etc et il faut faire attention à pas
uniquement évidemment se situer au
niveau individuel et de attention
médiatique accordée par par les opinions
publiques etc parce que
parce que du coup
si on si on en reste là on en reste un
peu dans un modèle aussi où au fond tout
ce qu'on espère tout ce qu'on peut
espérer c'est une forme de
d'opinion publique informée qui
appliquent sa charité à diverses causes
etc bon c'est un petit peu le un des
objectifs de la truite efficace mais je
crois qu'il faut aussi il faut aller
plus loin que ce modèle de l'action
individuelle et aussi parce que
je pense qu'il y aura nécessairement des
limites enfin voilà
dans la capacité d'attention et aux
capacités
S pour n'importe quel être humain
d'appréhender l'entièreté des causes et
de la misère dans le monde à tout moment
enfin ouais c'est c'est presque humain
d'être un si on imagine que la morale
exige d'être de se préoccuper de la
misère et de la souffrance et de la
justice partout dans le monde à tout
moment et dans sa juste proportion etc
enfin vous voyez c'est c'est quelque
chose évidemment d'impossible et
d'invitable et d'ailleurs enfin
j'imagine toi aussi tu vis ça un peu
mais pour travailler souvent sur ces
questions ça un certain poids
psychologique aussi pour le
vulgarisateur mais donc il faut pas
donner l'impression il me semble que
ce qu'on voilà qu'on dit aux gens vous
êtes des monstres parce que vous ne vous
préoccupez pas en permanence de toute la
misère du monde
il y a aussi le fait que voilà on
pourrait tous faire des efforts pour
s'émanciper de notre bien mais nous
vivons dans un monde extrêmement injuste
et dans lequel les institutions
et la coopération internationale sont
extrêmement défaillantes
il y a un grand défi une question
parfois que j'ai sur thomasoiles c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'intéresse pas
juste au fake news retirer tous les
mauvais contenus mais je pense que c'est
ces exemples qui m'ont vraiment qu'il y
a un problème de dans le problème c'est
aussi la priorisation de l'information
et notamment à priorisation relative de
différentes informations importantes par
ailleurs mais voilà notre attention est
limitée et
voilà il faut faire des choix le nombre
de vidéos qu'on peut regarder ou qui
nous sont recommandés et finis et il y a
forcément une bataille de de
l'attention entre sociétés soit des
sujets climatiques soit des sujets sur
aspire sécurité ou des sujets sur sur
les algodes de recommandation il y a
tellement de sujets importants il est
vraiment une question de comment est-ce
qu'on priorise tout ça
c'est d'essayer d'apporter un peu de
réponse à ces questions et avec pour
ambition aussi de pousser les gens de
nouveau à pas forcément agir uniquement
sur le mode individuel via des actions
caritatives et tout ça mais à
militer à plaider pour réformer le
système pour avoir une réponse
institutionnelle à tous et tous ces
problèmes qui sont
des news qui sont sous le radar
médiatique et qui sont voilà qui qui ont
besoin d'être d'être adressé de manière
beaucoup plus forte que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu as d'autres choses à
rajouter ou est-ce qu'on passe à la
comparaison
[Musique]
de prise en compte de ces chiffres c'est
quelque chose qui dépasse presque un peu
les réfugiés avec les victimes de la
guerre etc au moment
c'est un truc qui me fait
vraiment ça me fait grand chose au cœur
de joie des des par exemple des Chinois
ou des ou des Iraniens qui manifestent
et qui supporte les causes mutuelle
parce que du témoignage
ça fait un mouvement de solidarité
internationale sur des problèmes de
souffrance humaine et je pense que c'est
c'est vraiment bien quoi c'est vraiment
important et je pense aussi parce que
c'est ces gens se rendent compte que
leur réponse
enfin tout est lié quoi c'est pas juste
individuel pour le coup ça dépend de
même toute la communauté internationale
et il faut qu'une des actions
collectives mais du coup créer du lien
entre des communautés qui vivent
beaucoup de camp du monde sur ces sujets
je trouve ça
une question que j'avais posée à Mickaël
l'autre fois et c'est vraiment une
question pas si facile en fait que je
réfléchis mais c'est quel est le bilan
finalement de la Coupe du Monde est-ce
qu'il est positif ou est-ce qu'il est
négatif
notamment en termes d'empathie
humaniste on va dire à l'échelle
planétaire ce que d'un côté c'est c'est
des équipes nationales donc il y a un
fort mouvement
nationaliste à chaque fois mais en fait
les gens regardent pas mal les matchs
des autres équipes et
je pense qui est enfin
[Musique]
qui affirme que le visage de la Coupe du
Monde par les Chinois a causé des en
Chine mais faut bien se rendre compte
que les Chinois qui étaient enfermés
chez eux et qui pouvaient pas sortir à
cause de du confinement contre covid il
voyait des gens sourient et vivre
fêter ensemble et de des quatre coins du
monde quoi donc il y a quelque chose de
d'assez spécial dans cette dans la Coupe
du Monde du fait que il y a des gens de
quatre coins du monde qui qui font la
fête donc pas forcément enfin dans le
même stade bon pas forcément les uns à
côté des autres mais quand même ensemble
que
oui oui il y a certainement des choses
qui peuvent des dimensions réjouissantes
qui peut avoir à ces moments de
communion mondiale
etc bon après si c'était pas organisé
par la FIFA qui est
nationalieuse ou peut-être même pas ce
midi et enfin voilà au kata avec toutes
les
évaluations climatiques et les morts et
le problème qu'on connaît
j'aurais plus de
j'arriverais mieux à m'en réjouir quoi
mais je sais pas quel est le
j'espère que j'ai moi j'ai tellement
bien boycoté tout ça que j'ai pas suivi
du coup exactement
l'effet l'impact médiatique de la Coupe
du monde j'ai cru voir qu'il y avait
quand même une des audiences plutôt en
berne
mais après il y a aussi un débat sur la
question de est-ce que couvrir cette
coupe du monde et faire des reportages
autour justement sur la situation au
Qatar au niveau des droits de l'homme
sur les utopies
technosolutionnistes
aberrante
de ville climatisée etc enfin voilà
mettre le projecteur là dessus est-ce
que
ça a pas plus d'impact plus positif les
faitnettes je j'en sais rien je pense
qu'il faudra voir
par après
difficile de faire le contrefacture j'ai
pas voulu faire de vidéos là dessus
parce que
j'avais pas envie de me transformer en
monsieur boycott et Monsieur j'appelle
j'appelle j'appelle à des débats
qui peuvent en fait avoir une forte
dimension clivante dans la mesure où
c'est utilisé entre des personnes entre
des fans de foot et des moins fans de
foot en des communautés de niveau social
très différentes etc pour se pointer les
doigts le doigt les uns sur les autres
quoi les envers les autres
donc moi je respirais qu'il y a un
mouvement plus collectif de boycott et
qui ça marche mieux évidemment mais
voilà je j'avais pas envie d'en rajouter
une couche sur sur la question du
boycott personnellement je pense que
c'est tout a été pas mal de trucs ont
été bien dit en tout cas
je pensais plus au Coupe du monde en
général pas forcément celle-là parce que
notamment la prochaine tu me trompe pas
c'est aux États-Unis et le coup
environnemental
parce que du coup ils font des voyages
quatre camps des États-Unis entre les
matchs avec tous les supporters
qui était mais oui après et souvent
aussi
ces débats peuvent avoir un peu à côté
agaçant parce que parfois c'est il y a
des arguments beaucoup de souvent et des
arguments de mauvaise foi étonnamment et
du coup des arguments du type oui mais
quand c'était au Brésil ou quand c'était
là etc vous n'avez rien dit vous n'avez
pas alors ça enfin oui et à chaque fois
j'essaie de rappeler qu'on vit dans un
monde non idéal et que le fait qu'on
n'est pas dénoncé l'injustice à tel
moment dans le le monde dans le passé
etc ça ne m'implique pas qu'on aurait
plus le droit de on aurait plus le droit
de rien dire OK
c'est vrai que tu es bavard
en plus tu me relances
donc les écoles restent versus
Ukraine notre empathie visée laquelle
devrait être davantage recommandé alors
attendez moi que je vois le truc un peu
ouais
[Musique]
je vais mettre le lien dans le chat
alors laquelle doit être le plus
recommandé
[Musique]
je mettrai bon les deux j'ai du mal à
les gens qui demandent est-ce que est-ce
que
ça fait quelque chose de mettre au
milieu oui ça fait quelques choses dire
que deux vidéos sont aussi
recommandables l'une que l'autre c'est
une information importante pour
tournesol en particulier ça pousse
l'autre à voir nos score aussi
c'est à dire que oui en plus
la vidéo sur l'Ukraine est déjà classée
numéro 1 si je me trompe et donc ouais
ce qui n'est pas le cas sur YouTube sur
YouTube la vidéo éco-geste a fait
beaucoup plus de puzz bien sûr donc là
oui dans les tâches je trouve que c'est
pas mal
alors laquelle est plus fiable et non on
peut
[Musique]
la vidéo sur l'Ukraine avait un côté
plus expérimental j'ai fait ça en mode
podcast réaction à l'actualité etc donc
je n'ai pas étudié en détail les
questions la littérature sous l'empathie
etc j'ai résumé un petit peu tout ça
alors que la vidéo écogeste et je pense
beaucoup plus blindé et à plus de
prévention de effectivement d'être
précises donc je mettrai je sais pas moi
4 vers la gauche
c'est quand même se baser sur moins
d'études alors que les vidéos de droite
c'est plus un revue littérature
française oui mais ouais la vidéo droite
c'est surtout je pose des questions donc
en fait mais oui je suis d'accord que en
disant j'ai fait mon possible pour
rendre la vidéo de gauche la moins
trompeuse possible
en distinguant aussi ce qui était mon
opinion ce qui était de et voilà que
c'était quatre études
ok
quel est plus clair et pédagogique
je mettrais aussi
légèrement vers la gauche peut-être
1 2
2 2
partant et actionnable
important et actionnable ce magnifique
franglais
oui je dirais que la vidéo sur le biais
donc quand même plus
c'est un enjeu
plus essentiel de plus fondamental moins
une question de ouais technique quoi
est-ce que c'est actionnaire
pas évident parce que après à la fin de
la vidéo on sait pas si on a vraiment
des solutions très claire pour
une solution
c'est quoi
je pense la suite logique de la vidéo
c'est bon bah je m'intéresse un peu plus
à ce qui s'est passé en Syrie ou enfin
ou à d'autres choses
accessible non spécialiste
je dirais
j'ai plus à l'esprit vraiment parce que
je pense que
les bois peut-être que celle de celle de
l'Ukraine est un petit peu plus
accessible de sur la droite
[Musique]
divertissant et relaxant
alors bon ben voilà je vais de nouveau
devoir parler de il y a des blagues sur
le yaourt c'est super
[Rires]
ça fait un petit peu
plus de tentative du mot sur la question
des éco-gestes que je me suis moins
permise aussi sur une
sensible que l'Ukraine quoi donc je sais
pas moi 3 vers la gauche
stimulant et suscite la réflexion
[Musique]
des billets d'empathie pour moi c'est
une question beaucoup plus fondamentale
là où au fond la question des éco-gestes
et tout ça bon le jour on aura assez
d'étude empiriques on pourra résoudre
cette question une fois pour toutes et
on aura une réponse claire et une évoque
une fois que une fois qu'elle sera
communiqué par des vulgarisateurs et
écouter par des publics
plus ou moins cet espoir même si c'est
quand même un peu utopique mais un peu
plus que sur la question qui est
extrêmement normative extrêmement
fondamentale et politique de des billets
d'empathie et de l'extension de notre
capacité de reconversion morale donc je
mettrai ouais
5 vers la droite
diversité et inclusion
à la droite
encourage de meilleures habitudes
voilà j'ai du mal un peu à
des partager
disons attends par rapport à actionnable
du coup c'est quoi la différence encore
les habitudes c'est plus un truc du
quotidien ça serait
ouais ben alors peut-être un petit peu
plus sur la question des éco-gestes là
où on a quand même un peu plus des
habitudes claires de voilà mesurer votre
impact tout ça de à gauche
et résistant au retour négatif
je mettrai trois à gauche parce que même
j'ai pas eu beaucoup de retours négatifs
franchement j'ai eu un peu peur mais
finalement ça a été mais j'ai quand même
eu un ou deux quelques retours de gens
qui vont ils ont ont voulu lire ma vidéo
de manière pas très charitable et du
coup qui l'ont interprété comme le mec
cherche absolument à dire qu'il y a pas
de racisme
trucs comme ça
évidemment pas le cas
mais
voilà si on met des agents d'acacés si
on prête des intentions etc
je dirais que c'est j'ai eu quelques
retours comme ça mais ça va un petit peu
c'est un peu difficile ça parce que de
recevoir ça évidemment surtout j'ai
essayé justement de
peut-être un peu moins résistante
peut-être le sujet qui est aussi moins
résistant
négatif en général quoi
par exemple et du coup on va passer à ta
dernière vidéo
ah oui
alors donc celle que je recommande mais
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas dans le top
3 c'est ça exactement
ben oui alors je recommande la vidéo qui
s'appelle
négociation climatique ce moment où ça a
déraillé quelque chose comme ça justice
climatique ce moment où ça déraillé
[Musique]
c'est pas vraiment à ce moment là enfin
je n'étais pas présent etc mais
c'est censé être présenter effectivement
les tensions entre les États-Unis et la
Chine
et ça se passe bien au moment et à la
Coop
dont il est question mais donc ouais
c'est une vidéo que que j'ai ouais
sur lequel j'ai vraiment passé pas mal
de temps et qui me tient vraiment fort à
coeur parce que c'est vraiment c'est
l'histoire des négociations climatiques
qui est un sujet qui pourrait être
extrêmement ennuyeux et bureaucratique
le vocabulaire de l'on
la knuque
c'est la Convention de l'ONU climatique
les principes des responsabilités
respectives mes différenciés etc bref
mais en fait c'est j'ai découvert ça en
travaillant avec mon collègue
Pierre-André sur la vidéo sur la justice
climatique et partage des efforts c'est
un sujet passionnant et en fait je
trouve qu'on devrait tous avoir des
notions vraiment de l'histoire un peu de
ces négociations climatiques et de
l'histoire du coup de cet idéal de
justice climatique au niveau des coques
parce que enfin voilà moi-même j'avais
qu'une très vague idée voilà des noms
Kyoto la corde de Paris évidemment etc
mais j'avais pas tout pas tout en tête
et en fait il y a vraiment un truc voilà
et là il y avait aussi matière à un
petit peu raconter ça sous la forme d'un
récit avec différents chapitres
l'optimisme de Montréal l'espoir de Rio
le faux départ de Kyoto l'échelle de
Copenhague là c'est le drame là c'est le
la fin du deuxième acte ou tout semble
perdu et puis Paris un nouvel espoir on
laisse sur un espoir un petit peu bon à
moitié pourri sur la climatique mais je
vous laisse tirer vos conclusions mais
en tout cas et enfin avec pas mal
d'extraits aussi j'ai énormément fouillé
dans les extraits dans les pas fonds
YouTube des extraits des cops et de la
couverture médiatique très limitée des
vidéos notamment des vidéos postées par
des ONG poster par certains médias etc
de déclaration de
notamment je trouve une déclaration qui
est très
très forte de culinaldo de Greenpeace au
lendemain de l'échec de la Coop de
Copenhague qui qui parle là aussi de des
billets qu'on a dans les pays du Nord
billet évidemment vis-à-vis de notre
propre pomme et pas du reste du monde
et donc ouais moi je trouve c'est
une vidéo qui qui
est aussi important pour un petit peu
lutter contre un certain discours de
ouais on fait 36 Coop mais au final il
se passe rien et une coque de plus pour
rien etc c'est que du blablabla etc
et même si évidemment j'ai énormément
critique sur le processus des coques le
processus de l'ONU etc on peut pas dire
qu'ils se soient rien passé on peut pas
dire que on n'est pas été à certains
moments proches de d'avancer qui aurait
été assez significative et
je pense qu'il faut c'est un processus
il faut pas abandonner
même s'il faut sans doute le réformer et
ça donne un peu une idée quoi ça donne
un petit peu de une histoire de où on en
est et ça permet un petit peu de se
remettre à zéro et de suivre ça de
manière un petit peu plus
les pieds les pieds sur terre quoi
il y a beaucoup d'informations
[Musique]
je pense un des trucs qui m'a le plus
frappé dans cette vidéo c'est quand tu
parles de justice climatique et de
théorie de la justice climatique et que
tu compares aux engagements des
différents pays
on y est
oui mais ça c'est clair ça c'est le
twist de la fin de la vidéo
sans doute un petit peu
où est-ce que
donc c'est une ONG qui s'appelle éco
équity qui rassemble aussi pas mal de de
ngssd civile qui est fait des rapports
réguliers dans lequel il mesure
quel serait la juste part des différents
pays en fonction de différents principes
de justice climatiques qu'on développe
dans cette vidéo et dans la vidéo soit
partagée pas celui que le petit train va
pas et mais et il compare c'est juste
pas avec ce que les États effectivement
ont soumis comme comme effort volontaire
et ouais on y est effectivement
complètement pas quoi
donc voilà mais de nouveau c'est pas une
raison d'abandonner l'idéal du
stigmatique très clairement pas et
d'ailleurs enfin on l'a vu aussi avec
cette dernière COP avec le création d'un
fond sur les pertes et préjudices pour
préparer les dégâts du logement
climatique
on voit que nécessairement quand on se
demande et qui qui doit réparer qui doit
contribuer à quoi on en revient à sa
question là et donc on va devoir se
poser la question qu'on a mis un peu de
côté mis au frigo pendant tout un temps
là parce que c'est un petit peu trop
sensible
ça pose des pays d'une heure et du Sud
et tout ça mais il faudra se poser des
questions philosophiques et des
questions normatives
laquelle voilà les philosophes ont quand
même quelques trucs à dire et surtout
aussi qui ont le sur lesquels les
philosophes paradoxalement enfin on n'a
pas l'habitude mais on des réponses
assez pragmatiques avec des réponses
hybrides des principes qui mixent
plusieurs approches etc donc on pourra
pas dire que c'est les philosophes qui
bloquent
et puis ça me permet aussi de regrouper
avec les vidéos précédentes parce que je
pense que un des gros enjeux c'est une
question d'empathie aussi une question
de
se soucier davantage des personnes qui
sont directement exposés
et là il y a tout l'enjeu de l'attention
qui est énorme
ouais bien sûr et c'est aussi pour ça
que j'ai voulu faire la vidéo du coup
Kim Stanley Robinson c'était pour donner
un petit peu de chair un peu de corps à
ses appels à la justice climatique dire
c'est pas juste des statistiques c'est
pas juste des ou moins l'injustice dans
le monde
basé sur sur juste des arguments
abstraits mais ça enfin voilà montrer un
petit peu
en quoi
ça consiste concrètement l'impact du
jour emblématique dans un futur proche
dans des pays comme l'Inde mais il y en
a plein d'autres et à quoi on va faire
face très vraisemblablement et donc ça
se voit si ça permettait quand même de
de beaucoup de bien de bien amener ça
quoi mais donc ouais ça met vraiment une
vidéo que j'ai passé un temps dingue là
dessus j'ai essayé de faire un peu un
truc un peu plus en mode documentaire
qui prend un peu plus son temps j'ai
réutilisé aussi une super chouette vidéo
que je vous conseille si vous avez pas
le temps de vous taper les 28 minutes de
ma vidéo ce qui est un tort mais bon
c'est de regarder du coup une vidéo qui
s'appelle the history of clans
négociation in happy seconds donc
l'histoire de négociations climatiques
en 83 secondes par une chaîne qui
s'appelle Cicero climat
c'est une très chouette animation du
coup qui réduit un petit peu tout ça en
83 secondes donc
voilà j'en ai mis la plupart des
extraits mais
c'est dans un bon un bon résumé
[Musique]
différents états
ok
sur cette vidéo
[Musique]
alors je la compare avec quoi celle-ci
ça va être comparé avec la dernière donc
avec la meilleure selon la communauté de
tournesol ça veut dire que
[Musique]
un petit biaisé versus justice
climatique
oui là je dirais quand même devrait être
plus largement recommandé surtout mon
tournesol là il y a eu un traitement
injuste
c'est un scandale
c'est pas moi qui contrôle c'est la
communauté une petite main au foot
auprès des mois
peut-être que c'est une vidéo qui manque
de comparaison c'est peut-être que le
score est bloqué parce qu'il y a pas
assez de gens qui l'ont comparé
[Musique]
sans contributeur et en fait
la distribution des scores et assez
comparable entre les enfin jusque là il
y en a beaucoup moins
que la communauté tournesol et qui n'est
je pense pas sans lien avec la
communauté un peu Sainte-Foy et préférée
la question de des billets de
plus fréquentes dans ces mais donc ouais
voilà regardez l'autre aussi c'est cool
[Musique]
qu'il va falloir qu'on développe savoir
ce que je score et par manque de
contributeurs
alors donc trois camps à droite ou
est-ce que c'est moi
vers la justice climatique la justice
climatique est à droite sur mon sur la
vidéo
ok
fiable et non trompeur
j'espère les deux
j'espère que
ok j'espère qu'on est aussi peu trompeur
des deux cas
ok claire et pédagogique
en tout cas j'ai mis un effort
pédagogique plus grand dans celui de
droite donc je mettrai
deux points pour celle de droite OK
important et actionnable
c'est un peu ouais non non
accessible non spécialiste
accessible au nom spécialiste
[Musique]
je pense que les deux sont assez
accessibles
en tout cas on reprend vraiment dans les
bases dans les vidéos sur les
climatiques donc là aussi j'ai envie de
dire un peu
milieu
divertissant et relaxant
alors non on est quand même plus celle
de droite parce que du coup il y a les
petits extraits de dessin animé
des images relatives de chiens qui
regardent une cause de Trump
ou plus
je ne dirais pas que mes capacités à
faire de l'humour drôle mérite plus
qu'un 3 donc
stimulant et suscite la réflexion
peut-être quand même
à gauche à gauche historique
diversité et inclusion
difficile à les partager de nouveau
là-dessus je vois l'objectif quand même
de deux vidéos et assez semblable qui
est de se préoccuper de questions de
justice qui affecte le reste du monde et
surtout le sud global quoi
encourage de meilleures habitudes
voilà on termine avec des conseils des
tutos pratiques sur comment réaliser
votre justice climatique chez vous
donc ouais je dirais aussi middle parce
que c'est des gros sujets et sur lequel
je prétends pas pouvoir laisser le
viewer sur une solution
et enfin résister au retour négatif
du coup je mettrais ouais de 3 versets
de droite
jusqu'à
OK
on valide
et voilà donc il reste plus qu'une vidéo
dont on va parler et c'est du coup la
vidéo qui t'a le plus marqué
faire ça attention suspense
oui alors c'est difficile j'aurais pu
citer plein de trucs c'est les dangers
du réchauffement
je peux voir le titre exact je l'ai même
pas là
comment le réchauffement climatique va
bouleverser l'humanité
donc c'est le réveilleur avec le monde
et enfin moi elle m'a disons elle m'a
marqué dans la mesure où je trouve c'est
le meilleur vidéo qui résume un petit
peu qui résume l'impact les impacts du
réchauffement climatique de manière très
courte très Catchi c'est moins de 15
minutes avec en fait c'est donc bon
c'est le réveilleur c'est un excellent
vulgarisateur un excellent pédagogue
on dirait pas forcément que c'est le
meilleur au niveau du montage
des visuels mais justement il a un côté
plus voilà je de scientifiques etc mais
alors justement là c'est la rigueur du
réveillon avec la qualité du montage du
monde et ça donne un truc quand même
assez assez
percutant et moi je voilà je la fais
regarder à peu près dans chacun de mes
cours puisque quand même de parler de
climat dans la plupart de mes cours
et du coup je fais au moins regarder
celle-là quoi je pense que c'est hyper
important et aussi pour montrer un peu
voilà ces enjeux de justice climatiques
pourquoi est-ce pourquoi est-ce qu'on en
parle et
quels sont les inégalités d'impact
du changement climatique quoi et
notamment les diverses régions du monde
qui vont être rendues inhabitable
pendant
parfois
un nombre substantiel de jour voir dans
les pires scénarios bonne partie de
l'année etc les cycles de l'eau
l'élévation de niveau de la mer c'est
aussi une vidéo qui du coup qui illustre
très bien les concepts quoi on se
contente pas de citer des trucs comme je
viens de le faire là on illustre bien
comment ça marche et avec des exemples
très des chiffres très précis aussi du
nombre de millions de personnes
affectées dans chaque cas etc donc c'est
très très convaincant et je trouve c'est
vraiment une vidéo importante
voilà j'aurais pu citer aussi
me suffit reca petite chaîne qui
s'appelle silence forum
refusé ça
ne sera sur cette sur cette
parlé aussi qui font du très bon boulot
et plein d'autres mais donc du coup
ouais moi c'était un petit peu c'est un
peu ça que j'avais envie de
mettre en avant
de cette vidéo je me demande si le score
est également pas saturé tu vois parce
que la plupart des gens mettent plus de
et pas mal au dessus de 60 et 80 est-ce
qu'on est qu'à 602 donc si je voulais
augmenter le score de cette vidéo vous
pouvez qui la noter
positivement monsieur mais on a besoin
de plus de contributeurs pour avoir des
scores plus juste et il a raison pour
laquelle on a des scores qui sont
saturés comme ça c'est pour des
questions de sécurité
vous là vous venez exactement
qui font que s'il y a beaucoup de
comptes non certifié qui note une vidéo
le fait cumuler va être restant mais
tout le monde affecte tous les scores
puis aussi vous pouvez avoir plus de
droits de vote en plus garanti si vous
avez une adresse email attachée de
confiance ou si quelqu'un qui a une
adresse email rattachée à mon domaine de
confiance ce porte garant pour vous avec
l'option en haut à droite et je ne vois
pas
sur la page comparaison là si vous avez
sur en haut à droite vous pouvez vous
porter garant
voilà donc ce cyclo enfin si quelque
chose à rajouter sur la vidéo un dernier
message à passer
non c'était cool merci de l'invitation
je suis très honoré j'espère que j'ai
pas saoulé tout le monde à parler de mes
vidéos pendant deux heures
il y a au moins une personne qui était
intéressée
de pouvoir aussi en profiter pour mettre
un peu le projecteur sur sur tournesol
qui est un super cool projet donc
voyons c'est très chouette
prévu pour le prochain je te force à
spoiler
je suis pas beaucoup en avance
donc du coup j'ai contacté personne
tu aimerais mais alors là ça fait deux
fois qu'on parle un peu pas mal du
climat et en fait ça c'est il y a
beaucoup de recommandations donc c'est
normal mais du coup j'aimerais quand
même quelque chose un peu différent et
un peu climat aussi
je sais pas si je devrais annoncer alors
que j'ai pas encore pour prévenir la
personne donc
après ça sera en janvier donc
pas faire ça pour les fêtes mais ce sera
une personne vachement
vachement stylé non vachement vachement
si j'ai forcément besoin il y a que des
gens stylés un critère d'entrée pour
être invité c'est d'avoir au moins trois
vidéos bien notées sur tournesol donc
c'est
forcément que la crème de la crème
et bien noté c'est à partir de quoi
positifs quoi
ici surtout au sol parce que
notre médiane est à zéro du coup
comme il y a beaucoup de contenu de
qualité sur tournesol il y a des vidéos
qui ont des scores c'est-à-dire c'est un
truc un peu gênant c'est qu'il y a des
très bonnes vidéos qui ont des scores
négatifs
[Musique]
forcément
après comme je disais en soi déjà
suffisamment de compliments ça va
j'ai des idées pour
avoir des échelles de score qui soit
plus quand le score est positif c'est
que la vidéo est bien
mais bon il y a beaucoup de travail
entre avoir une idée
vérifier qu'elle marche bien vous pouvez
éteindre de sécurité et ensuite le
développer le déployer le tester ça
prend du temps malheureusement tout ça
ah bon
ça ça prend du temps mais du coup si on
pouvait avoir plus de contributeurs à
tous ces sujets à la fois sur les maths
sur le développement le code
promotion sur le financement et tout ça
vous êtes on a besoin de vous comme tu
veux bien le
bien Daisy
[Musique]
dans la discorde sur lequel on
s'organise
le lien doit être quelque part dans le
chat en tout cas sur le site de
tournesol donc voilà venez et puis
contribuer plus de contributeurs c'est
plus de visibilité aussi c'est des
meilleurs vidéos
identifiées plus de meilleures vidéos
identifiées collaborativement et
on a besoin de vous
bah sur ce je dis merci à tous pour
d'être venu d'avoir regardé
d'avoir subi Maxime pendant deux heures
et puis merci beaucoup Maxime dates
d'être venu et je vous dis à une
prochaine ciao merci Salut tout le monde